doré 100 cas de contamination à la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim en
alsace pose une nouvelle fois la
question de la sécurité et du recours à
la sous traitance en fait aujourd'hui
80% des activités de maintenance sont
assurés par des salariés extérieurs à
edf certaines sociétés estiment donc
prendre plus de risques les agents edf
ces inquiétudes sont elles font des
éléments de réponse avec frédéric
mentale et marie laborie dans une
centrale nucléaire
il faut régulièrement aspirer les
poussières radioactives
nettoyez vérifier ou ressouder des
tuyaux des opérations délicates voire
dangereuse confié à 80% à des sociétés
extérieures à edf
ces travailleurs on les surnomme les
nomades du nucléaire il face d'une
centrale à une autre d'un chantier
amiante au nettoyage d'une cuve
radioactive pendant dix ans christian
bollini a fait partie de ces précaires
de l'atome
le boulon dangereux ça le le sale boulot
est fait par les prestataires et pour
preuve il pointe son carnet médical
il passe régulièrement de la case ras
rien à signaler a contaminé sans
entraîner d'examens complémentaires
on m'a laissé croire qu'il y avait de la
prévention en or
je me suis rendu compte qu'il n'y aurait
pas la prévention il n'y avait pas les
moyens de protection n'y avait pas de
tout ce qu'il était prévu la part des
prestataires dans les centrales est
considérable 600 entreprises
vingt mille salariés c'est-à-dire autant
que d'employer le dr et pour la
direction
pas question de parler d'un manque de
sécurité pour ses sous traitants
l'ensemble du personnel auxquels nous
faisons appel est un personnel formé à
la radioprotection compétent
techniquement et dont on suit
médicalement les aptitudes au même titre
que le personnel ne détient pas de
différence de traitement entre le
personnel quel que soit son entreprise
d'appartenance mais à chaque opération
délicate comme ici au coeur d'une
centrale les prestataires s'expose à des
radiations les normes actuelles
équivalent à deux radios des abdominaux
par an mais selon cette chercheuse les
sous traitants sont beaucoup plus
exposés que les agents edf dans l'ancien
que nous avons fait les différences
d'exposition à l'aide pour une dose
mensuelle moyenne par travailleur était
de 5 à 15 fois plus élevé entre
les travailleurs extérieurs par rapport
aux agents idéal sur les 35 sous
traitants suivi par cette scientifique
cinq sont décédés d'un cancer pour
autant difficile de déterminer si ces
maladies étaient liés à leur travail
dans les années à venir
l'emploi massif de robots pourraient
limiter les expositions radioactive des
salariés